l'académie des neuf avec maurice biraud
bonjour et flint en dry all herman avec
aussi mademoiselle laurence badie perez
est fier yves lecoq en invité eric
tabarly
sheila l'invité de la semaine
était
j'aime les cieux bonjour bienvenue dans
cette académie des neuf avec tout de
suite enfin des éclaircissements sur le
terrible litige qui nous a opposé hier
matin à souvenait la question était la
suivante mesdames messieurs les
académiciens voulez vous me citer cinq
ingrédients pour la préparation de la
brandade de morue
selon rose montigny l'académicien choisi
était laurence badie bonjour vous
insistiez en disant qu'il y avait de la
haine est un oui selon rose montini
morue bien des salles et huile d'olive
les frais non écrémé pain de mie coupé
en triangle et frites au beurre sel
poivre muscade et alors le litige s'est
posée lorsque vous a dit mais non mais
non il y adeux lie tous les académiciens
ont dit mais oui mais oui il ya de là
nous avons téléphoné à de grands
spécialistes de la cuisine
certains maîtres de l'aïe certains noms
m pap et date comme rose montini
d'ailleurs et c'était la question tout
simplement
voici la définition donnée par
d'une encyclopédie de cuisine dans la
réputation n'est plus à faire et qui
sème à tout vent
ce plat qui vient du languedoc ne
comporte pas die
mais en abusant provence quelquefois est
en tout cas monsieur fukui
en tout cas une chose est certaine oui
quand même le dire aux françaises et aux
français oui je pose des questions oui
dans le cassoulet il y a des haricots
alors je vous présente maintenant des
candidats qui sont avec nous aujourd'hui
patricia bonjour qui êtes-vous patricia
je m'appelle patricia couché ce qui je
travaille à l'edf à paris à nous
d'écrire de direction oui non et se dire
on va dire que vous serez certainement
courant tout au long de l'émission les
pâtis oui mais je sentais vos lèvres
frémir et et quand avoir d'eau vous êtes
là depuis hier nous vous connaissons
c'est là et qui vous a sauvé en quelque
sorte
maintenant notre premier rendez vous
avec ou sans ail les 9 15
la règle du jeu vous la connaissez la
ligne a tracé un petit signe distinctif
pour chacun des candidats un rond pour
patricia une croix pour arnaud c'est
patricia qui commence avec qui vous
voulez vous jouer patricia avec perez
pradier bien sûr qu'ils se trouvent dans
la case e perrette voici la question
quel est le chanteur français qui s'est
lui même surnommé le fantôme de la
télévision en raison du faible nombre de
ses passages sur le petit écran
top chrono aïe aïe aïe
attention ce que vous allez déjà père
est le chanteur français très connu de
grand talent qui c'est qui ces noms qui
s'est lui-même surnommé le fantôme dans
la télévision
le village les vues souvent à la télé
et c'est pas facile de donner un sens et
bien c'est jean ferrat qui lui même
s'est surnommé le fantôme de la
télévision et nous le regrettons
merci père est de pradier on va de rien
c'est à vous maintenant arnaud de jouer
avec qui je rejoue avec ce père est avec
père est radié de quel grand film
exotiques
le célèbre western 17 mercenaires futile
le remake père est allé lily les corps
et ils étaient combien à votre avis les
sept samouraïs très bonne réponse de
perrette pradier les applaudissements du
public vampires et dîna deux courts
arnaud patricia c'est à vous avec qui
vous voulez vous jouer
moi je suis libre avec maurice biraud
voici la question maurice à partir de
quel mésaventure personnelle
oui l'industriel allemand abraham neiman
utile l'idée d'inventer le système de
sécurité qui porte son nom
top chrono 30 secondes parce que on lui
avait volé son vélo
non simplement je pense qu'on lui avait
tout simplement volé sa voiture à ce
pauvre homme est exactement faudrait
bien sûr de maurice biraud ensuite il a
fait du cinéma sous le nom de paul
newman un secours de 1934
quelqu'un lui voler sa voiture devant
son usine et il invente un ce système de
sécurité c'est bien pour vous patriciens
premier rond devant maurice biron garder
que faites-vous arnaud je joue avec eric
tabarly eric tabarly bonjour bienvenue
dans cette académie voici la question
qu'elle était qu'elle est plutôt en fait
la réelle désignation du 1er novembre
top chrono 30 secondes qu'elle est en
fait la réelle désignation du 1er
novembre
eric elle promet c'est la toussaint
exactement c'est la toussaint ne vont
pas chercher plus loin
c'est à dire la fête de tous les saints
et et non le jour des morts c'est bien
la toussaint et c'est que bon c'est
quand même le 14 juillet c'est la
bastille c'est la bastille puis se
tournant par le plus bravo eric tabarly
et merci une deuxième coin attention
patricia elle se jouer maintenant avec
attention regardez bien maghrib lucien
un mon avis il faut jouer avec paul
ekman s'engager pour moi là
je crois un je crois comme vous le savez
paul chaque vendredi les cadeaux à
gagner aux enchères sont données sous
forme d'anagramme dans l'académie des
neuf à ce propos andré breton en réalisa
une assez étonnante que je vous donne
avida dollars elle s'attaque est un
grand artiste de réputation
internationale qui est cet artiste top
pendant 30 secondes
or on ne peut rien vous cacher pour lui
c'est que je le connais ah bon et oui je
fais un petit peu de suspense là pour
patricia mais je sais parce que en plus
c'est joli à deux titres c'est un
anagramme mais aussi ça dit bien ce que
ça veut dire quand on sait de qui il
s'agit puisque il s'agit de salvador
dali très bonnes réponses salvador dali
excellente réponse à vis d'un taulard on
n'applaudit pas paul hermann merci enfin
à deux tours pâtissière 1 à 2 pour
arnaud arnaud qui vient de voir sa ligne
s'envoler et qui tente autre chose
maintenant avec qingling d'andré evelyn
evelyn pourquoi peut-on dire que
l'écrivain russe ivan tourguéniev était
une grosse tête
je pense que ça a l'air tellement facile
mais parce qu'il était très très
intelligent alors il avait un gros
cerveau peut-être vivre de windows
c'est ça moi je vous dis oui je vous dis
d'accord venez donnez moi le tri bête
mais si sage non mais tenez moi le poids
approximatif du cerveau d'ivan
tourgueniev 50 kilos un poids au hasard
25 kg
la tête ça a un côté des pieds 25 kg non
non parce que naturellement cet homme de
lettres bah tiens curieux record
physique en effet il possédait l'un des
plus gros cerveau humain
deux kilos de 0,2 bien sûr patricia vous
jouer automatiquement avec pour contrer
votre adversaire avec celle a bien su
bien bonjour chela quel est le prénom
d'origine grecque et qui indiquent une
personne qui veille ou qui est éveillé
alors plein de prénoms chela à ce qu'une
quel est le prénom d'origine grecque et
qui indiquent une personne qui veille
qui est éveillé donc ça vient du grec
c'est un prénom le nom plein de prénom
ni donne chez nous bien de chez nous des
prénoms masculins guy non c'est pas mal
en ce qui concerne la première lettre on
continue c'est pas ça c'est pas ça
gérard noël yves non la première lettre
de guy était bien la première lettre
c'était grégoire du grec et grégorien
qui veille à la halle à mon dieu quelle
souplesse j'arrive ce qui est acquis
maintenant de jouer c'est avoue arnaud
avec celle à celle à 100 corps moi mais
c'est une attaque est décidément celle
là encore un prénom quel est le prénom
peu courant faut bien le dire du petit
parisien de dix ans que tout le monde
recherche a pendant plus de 15 jours
le 10 novembre dernier top chrono 30
secondes il y avait des affiches partout
dans neuf ans que j'étais pas à paris
alors
des excuses qui sait qu'ils m'aident
philippe j'ai pas moi s'il vous plaît un
prénom à die
comment as tu aie aie attendez on
rajoute une lettre à des iris non oui je
sais pas je ne sais pas si on peut
accepter
on me fait ça donc bravo c'était il
manquait à 10 cm sont annoncés
altaïr altaï c'est ce que vous vouliez
dire frénétiquement c'était pas mal
politiquement c'était bien c'était bien
bravo sheila et bravo à arnaud quittera
sa ligne regardez une ligne de trois
croix 140 à 2 pour arnaud 20 petits à 2
pour patricia est tout de suite je vais
aller rejoindre notre invité du jour
avant de jouer au dernier de 9
eric tabarly je ne sais pas si c'est une
idée mais j'ai l'impression que vous
êtes plus tranquille plus décontracté à
la barre de votre bateau eric tabarly
que dans l'une des cases de l'académie
des neuf jeux le troc ou pas je suis pas
tu peut contracter non parce que vous
êtes vous êtes plus à l'aise sur votre
bateau dans votre domaine c'est bien
normal et sur l'eau alors vous êtes là
parce que vous venez de faire paraître
un livre en barque avec tabarly
alors à qui est il destiné ce livre au
aux amateurs auront aux spécialistes de
la mer ou à ceux qui débutent tout
simplement
oui c'est un fait un livre d'initiation
oui en particulier pour les jeunes mais
au fond qui peut s'adresser à des moins
jeunes aussi qui débute alors eric
tabarly et pédagogue
ben peut dire que ce livre il faut le
dire est remarquablement fait avec des
explications d'abord des expériences
personnelles vous concernant
on y reviendra dans quelques instants et
puis des croquis des explications et
c'est à dire que en lisant attentivement
le bouquin ensuite on peut le jeter aux
flammes et se jeter à l'eau non parce
que
on peut pas prendre uniquement dans un
livre il faut quand même il faut quand
même un petit peu de pratique et
quelques
quelqu'un qui vous donne des conseils
quand même aussi sur l'eau pour débuter
je pense alors je parlais d'expériences
personnelles
est-ce qu'on peut évoquer leurs deux
mots votre première traversée d'abord
quel âge aviez-vous bien je devais
j'avais dans les 12 13 ans par l'âme et
j'avais aider un copain finir le genre
de père histoire à voile une série sera
voile et c'est ce que vous avez fait
comme traverser et alors on était en
était à préfailles en loire atlantique
est ce qu'on avait nous toujours à nous
barrer l'horizon s'était noirmoutier oui
alors c'était c'était grand rêve d'aller
à noirmoutier est alors un jour où le
vent était favorable
il y avait un bon vent d'est on est
parti pour noirmoutier puis le vent le
vent beaucoup fraîchit pendant notre
traversée
quand on est arrivé là bas avec avec
notre engin il n'était pas question de
revenir contre le vent on a laissé la
pire histoire là bas et puis à pied
on est rentré à la maison on a fait
toute l'île de noirmoutier toute la cre
on est rentré très tard le soir et on
était bien accueillie par les parents
c'est à dire bien accueillie par les
parents bazire chez une bonne raclée une
bonne raclée finalement si cette raclée
qui est au départ de deux de la carrière
de tabarly ou pas oh non non non non ça
marche ça n'a pas autant que ça merci
pour nous avoir raconté cette traversée
et puis embarque avec tabarly pour tous
ceux qui auraient là la vocation de la
mer pourquoi pas il faut bien commencer
par le début par de précieux conseils
merci eric tabarly vous allez jouer avec
nous maintenant vous allez jouer avec
arnaud première question c'est un vrai
ou faux à votre avis eric ans dort mieux
dans une pièce bien chauffé ou dans une
pièce on dort mieux pardon dans une
pièce bien chauffée que dans une pièce
peu chauffé vrai ou faux
faut vous dites faut vous êtes d'accord
arnaud et c'est tout à fait faux eric
tabarly a raison bonne réponse nous
applaudissons
la température idéale la température
idéale pour un bon sommeil cette
température se situe entre 16 et 18
degrés celle à marilyn monroe tomba
amoureuse et épousa un écrivain
américain henry miller vrai ou faux est
ce que vous êtes d'accord patriciens
vous êtes d'accord et non c'est arthur
miller
au revoir celle à tout à l'heure dave
voici la question
new york est la capitale de l'état du
même nom ouais vrai arnaud et albanie
alors dave 1 ces fonds c'est une erreur
merci des vents voir tout à l'heure
brice maurice biraud oui oui oui
le cuir est un apéritif inventé par le
chanoine du même nom absolument
absolument pas ce qu'il aimait bien ça
le charme d'un alain vous ne sonne et
pas un patricien c'est dire que vous
êtes d'accord avec maurice biraud
l'auteur du questionnaire maintenant je
me des gants on a remarqué un gie par
l'opa question il ya des lanières pas
d'âge je ne dis plus à l'auteur du
questionnaire me précise ce mélange de
vin à ligoter de crème de cassis ne fut
pas trouvé par le célèbre chanoine
pittoresque député maire de dijon
il fallait donc dire faux merci à votre
santé monsieur foucault evelyne d'andry
le vêtement appelé ulster est en fait un
kilt irlandais elster donc c'est un kilt
vous dites faut vous êtes d'accord
arnaud est très bien bonne réponse était
un piège l'ulster en matière
d'habillement mais je n'ai fait que vous
mais l'un est un pardessus long c'est à
vous paul herman le spiro graff est un
appareil qui sert à faire des ellipses
et autres motifs circulaires en dessin
artistique ou industrielles alors vous
voulez bien me dire ce que vous faites
quand vous voulez mesurer votre
respiration goût et jours c'est faux
patricia d'accord écoles enfin c'est
tout à fait faux c'est bien entendu pour
mesurer la capacité pulmonaire bonne
réponse classique
bonne réponse de paul hermann laurence
badie bossue
le terme américains brunch et la
contraction de breakfast et de lunch
vrai ou faux
oui c'est vrai vous dites que c'est vrai
arnaud ne sonne pas arnaud est d'accord
c'est tout à fait vrai le brunch est un
repas pris en fin de matinée deux
langues tenant lieu de petit déjeuner et
le repas de midi bonne réponse pérenne
pradier et laurence parle très bien le
vrai nom de l'acteur comique américain w
-c fields et oui oui william claude doc
infidels vrai ou faux j'irai je dirais
faux faux patricia d'accord avec
laurence ont contredit pas les
écologistes avec ce que vous vous rendez
vous il fallait dire fou merci au revoir
il fallait dire vrai merci au revoir
perdre pradier privé yves lecoq
il existe des diamants de toutes les
couleurs vrai ou faux c'est vrai c'est
en effet vrai lorsqu'il a eu nos
particulièrement remarquable le diamant
est dit blanc bleu mais il existe des
diamants nommé rose bleu cognac
champagne jonquilles et ses bonnes
réponses
éric tabard vie les chevaux dorment
debout
vrai ou faux vrai vrai patricia ne sonne
pas vous avez bien raison vrai ils
dorment aussi souvent debout que couché
sur le flanc mais bonne réponse c'est
acquis maintenant c'est à evelyne
d'andry je suis là les oiseaux lalouette
deschamps ne chante qu'en automne et au
printemps
vrai ou faux vrai vous dites vrai
marneux réagi arnaud sonne et arnaud a
raison c'est faux elle chante toute
l'année je regrette merci il me faut
vous départager maintenant paul hermann
des homophones connaissez-vous le
principe des homophones je vous donne
l'exemple le plus célèbre de l'académie
des neuf rapaces et villes d'italie
il faut répondre milan milan on est
d'accord homophones états du brésil
'pour d'israël c'est encore pour moi oui
mais non ça c'est que j'avais répondu
non mais milan c'était l'exemple mais
c'est moi qui voulais donner
oui mais ça n'a pas d'importance on le
donne de bons ils le 13 septembre tous
les jours et a dû brésil peur d'israël
10 secondes pour d'israël et quoi états
du brésil est plat et à un état du
brésil selon la cr eux je regrette merci
colombie brésil israël gauderman
laurence badie oui rivière allemande et
verbe qui désigne un mouvement allait à
2 1 er a laissé le verbe qui désigne un
mouvement et c'est une rivière allemande
e merci de vous êtes sûr qu'on prend
l'eau salée yves le je ne pense pas à
mon vieux coq lettres et reid chez
d'appli la pluie bonne réponse d'yves
lecoq
attention eric tabarly grain et ennui
grain et ennui
et oui c'était un pépin la graine de ses
pains et l'ennui avoir un pépin
merci eric tabarly à tout à l'heure le
dernier des neuf c'est yves lecoq qui va
jouer pour patricia 100 anneaux
supplémentaires attention organes et
moyens de communication langage non lang
lang pas de réponse d'yves lecoq et 100
à 2 supplémentaires pour vous patricia
150 à 2 patricia brigitte vous remets
vos gains 190 à 2 pour arnaud au
troisième et dernier rendez-vous pour
permettre aux candidats d'obtenir des
aides supplémentaires voici les neuf à
la cote
[Musique]
endicott établi par le vote du public
ici au théâtre de lempire des thèmes
choisis c'est vous qui allez commencer
patricia le premier thème voici les
cotes les villes d'amérique du nord et
centrale de plus de quatre millions
d'habitants
combien misez-vous d'abord et avec qui
regardez bien la grille avec paul
hermann paul hermann combien voulez vous
misez ii à 2,40 40 à 2 avec paul hermann
paul cinq villes d'amérique du nord et
centrale de plus de quatre millions
d'habitants
top chrono une de san francisco 3
d'amérique centrale rio non non c'est un
arrêt du sud mexique denver non mexico
oui ce qui fait qu avant qu'une ça y est
c'est la 5ème en manque une souffler
mois détroit dallas non non non non
houston non les wheeler sunday souffre à
une seconde de la fin
il a manqué qu'une seule il manquait
detroit détroit philadelphie pardon
félicitations paul hermann bravo
patricia bien jouer 400 à 2 arnaud c'est
à vous relever le défi les parties de
l'oeil humain
1 combien rentrent à 2 40 à 2 subjective
lecoq
yves lecoq il veut attendre et dès
qu'ils vivent le coq
s'il vous plaît quatre partis quatre
parties de l'oeil humain top chrono
l'iris la pupille le cristallin la
corneille le oui voilà avec
félicitations et le coq
bravo il est inimitable 430 pour 400 à
votre tour patricia a les ingrédients à
réaliser le rôti de porc exotiques
il n'y a pas d'âge je le dis tout de
suite pourtant assez bon dans le port
avec qui jouer vous patricia avec
laurence badie
alors attention combien de l'ado
misez-vous 30 30 m c'est bien c'est bien
laurence badie à nous deux à nous deux
bandits les voulez vous me citer quatre
ingrédients servant à réaliser le rôti
de porc exotiques
oui un wii 2 nous j'ai compris du sucre
de la banane
ouais ça fait toujours demain je réalise
à de l'huile de l'huile non on va pas
compter l'huile et puis quoi c'est pas
du beurre c'était alors alors
l'ananas a fait 3 il manque le principal
dans un rôti pour une sonnerie qui part
voilà
laurence badie bien c'est tout nos
conditions au tour de condiments à
laurence badie bien entendu il y avait
du beurre du sel du poivre de la
cannelle des pommes de terre sautées de
la compote chaude et j'ai la référence
de l'auteur du questionnaire que je
salue voilà alors c'est à vous
maintenant si vous patricia kenneth
jouer nous sommes d'accord arnaud les
noms des deux grey devant un butin de 0
à 10 constitue en échelle de beaufort je
sais qu'ils ont vaincus 2 200 à 2 avec
eric tabarly ouhlala vous tentez donc
400 à 2 puisque la cote des risques et
de 2 contre 1 eric tabarly voulez vous
me citez s'il vous plaît trois noms des
degrés devant constituant une échelle de
beaufort très compliqué top chrono calme
oui un vent faible 2 jolie brise jolie
brise 3 c'était 3 qu'il fallait oui
encore quelques-uns allez bonne brise
bonne brise
vent frais vent frais grands frais
grands frais quand ça commence a pu
rigoler du tout devant coup de vent est
encore plus terrible
pour adam à mon avis il a fait du bateau
on avait ya ça me regarde pas merci eric
tabarly très bien joué et arnaud 632
vous prenez la tête patricia les
républiques fédérées de l'urss lerman
combien de l'audience alors alors
combien de 2 50 50
paul trois républiques fédérées pour moi
j'aime l'histoire de l'urss en hiva top
chrono
la sibérie chan et la sibérie n'est pas
sur ma liste
l'ukraine n'est pas sûr maintenant non
plus oui une telle bêtise c'est fort
mais non j'ai pensé mais qui ça mais je
crois pas bonne réponse de l'ouzbek qui
sinon pensez aux villes où tristan mais
il en manque une l'arménie la
biélorussie les stones il géorgie la
lettonie la république socialiste
soviétique de russie aussi un il fallait
ma cité quand même le turkménistan etc
etc et bien patricia non et pour
conclure maintenant est venu avec arnaud
des types de climat doux 50 à 2 avec
yves le floch yves lecoq des types de
climat il m'en faut 3 tempéré un
continental deux noms méditerranéen
méditerranéen 3 excellente réponse
d'yves lecoq
allah est bien le score final c'est vous
une nouvelle fois arnaud qui l'emporté
avec 930 à 2 442 pour patricia qui sera
je pense les dépenses et vendredi dans
les enchères des neuf
il me reste une bonne minute le temps
pour moi de vous préciser que nous vous
attendons nombreux aux enregistrements
de l'académie des 9
il suffit de venir retirer vos
invitations gratuites ici au théâtre
d'un empire 41 avenue de wagram à paris
d'autre part si vous souhaitez prendre
la place d'arnaud de patricia vous nous
écrivez l'académie des 9 41 avenue de
wagram à paris
[Musique]